ce véhicule a été impliqué dans un assez
avec délit de fuite l'autre soir et la
voiture que vous avez sauvagement
embouti coûté extrêmement cher de
sobriété normalisé je procède à un 4 0 2
c'est quoi capture de fouille du
véhicule est saisi
alors ça va les gars bon allez mettez
les mains sur la tête
souple est faite de petits tours sur
vous même c'est bien ouais non
bascule du bassin en gardant les mains
sur la tête bascule du bassin ouais
comme ça non on amplifie le mouvement
vous pouvez voir ce qui se passe
derrière mais qu'est ce qui se passe
derrière on bouge toi et bouge on bouge
ça fait longtemps que vous me regarder
danser